where is he to do from the Kung Pao Quan  towel all right right if you broke into  your room why am I not looking at his  broken body did you stuff him under the  bed  no I wasn't able to detain him so what  happened he came to deliver a message he  said the Quang Tao are trafficking women  into Los Angeles that first truck  arrives soon so he tipped you off to a  quant el operation it why why would he  do that I don't know maybe he disagreed  with the plan well maybe he's pulling  you into a trap it's possible no it's  probable come on you know these guys  play dirty and what do you think they'd  do to one of their own for betraying the  family that'd be a serious punishment a  spanking is serious punishment these  guys take heads so who's gonna be crazy  enough to turn oh no you're right but we  can't just ignore this not if there are  innocent lives at stake I I have to  agree let's just watch your backs and  stick close together